when you think about a couple of areas i
just want to throw out ideas to you and
you kind of tell me uh where you guys
are how you think about it so let's
start with the one you just mentioned
which is this idea of uh the city and
the state both have access to power
there's obviously companies within the
city and state that uh that generate
power as well uh tell us a little bit
more about this idea of nuclear power uh
generation for bitcoin mining right we
obviously saw the uh president el
salvador talk about kind of volcano
energy mining that got everyone all
excited um but is there a path uh here
in miami or in southern florida uh to go
ahead and start mining bitcoin using
nuclear power
there's absolutely a path and it's not
just nuclear power by the way it's clean
power right we and clean power can
constitute a variety of things nuclear
being one of the uh you know one of the
sources that is a clean and that is
obviously um
inexpensive in the sense that it's
expensive from the capital side but once
you have the capital uh in place it's
actually on a per unit basis are quite
inexpensive that you know uh electricity
here in miami is one of the lowest uh
places in terms of rates in the country
uh but you also have solar uh you also
have uh you know hydroelectric and
natural gas as opportunities and what
you want to do is you want to tap into
under producing
assets in the energy field or or maybe
untapped energy assets that are clean
and and create a way to maximize those
assets so i know
companies in florida right now that i've
been conversing with that are doing just
that uh in a variety of cities across
florida uh they're analyzing energy
assets they're looking at you know the
portfolio of cleanliness and they're
also looking at the portfolio of of
underperformingness and saying hey we'll
take up this we'll take up this uh you
know this this on
this pent up demand if you will and we
can put it to good use and so i think
that's just really smart uh and one of
the things that people don't understand
about bitcoin mining is that it it takes
up such a small fraction of percentage
of the energy that we consume in fact
in the united states we waste
significantly more energy
significantly more energy than bitcoin
mining consumes
and so when you think about another
topic that people are really interested
in uh putting bitcoin on the city's
balance sheet how do you
evaluate you know uh is that possible
where are you in that process
you know it it may require some state
law changes so we're we're working with
the state um on creating a crypto
friendly environment for our state uh
which requires uh you know how we
classify bitcoin regulation banking uh
and of course things like holding it on
our balance sheet uh you know and so i
think it's important uh for us to
continue along that process and and and
every day that bitcoin becomes more and
more mainstream uh i think uh it is a
good day uh you know for the city to
hold it as an asset uh particularly
given some of the levels of inflation
that we're seeing um in in the cpi uh
you know over the last few months
and then one of the other things uh that
recently happened which i've been
fascinated with is this idea of uh
building things on top of bitcoin uh one
of the things that got built was miami
coin and for those that don't know uh it
is uh built on top of bitcoin using
smart contracts from uh uh stacks and
my understanding of miami coin is uh
people can go in they can buy this
there's a mining functionality and about
30 of the mining rewards has been
diverted and it's kind of set aside for
uh a city uh of which the city that has
a choice as to whether to uh kind of
claim it or receive that amount um you
guys had a vote a couple of weeks ago
and ultimately chose to go ahead and
claim that reward which at the time i
think was kind of you know four four and
a half million dollars now i believe it
may be as high as six or seven million
dollars um and so talk a little bit just
about that initiative why go ahead and
accept it um and then how you kind of
see the relationship with that moving
forward
yeah well i i think the first thing and
this thing's to say that what it is and
what it isn't right so i think the first
thing to say is it's not the city didn't
create it right so it's not a
city-created um
uh initiative right it's something that
was created by an organization called
city coins which is sort of a network of
people that created it uh and as you
said the protocol for mining
uh you know creates a benefit that puts
a percentage of
of of what is uh stacked uh into a a
wallet essentially for the city now as
you said also it is it is a
a
you know cryptocurrency that is created
and based on bitcoin and so i think
that's something that maybe people
haven't fully digested
and why is that because the bitcoin
blockchain which is the most secure
blockchain on the planet
is for bitcoin
and so stocks which is you know a
blockchain that allows for smart
contract functionality on the bitcoin
blockchain uh which is again the best
most diverse most secure blockchain on
the planet creates more functionality
for the bitcoin blockchain and allows
for interaction of bitcoin rewards in
this process
so uh
again the the miami coin is something
that is an offshoot of stocks and
bitcoin
and so like you said it has it has
generated
for the city somewhere in the vicinity
of
seven million dollars is handing it to
me over seven million dollars uh from
when it started and this was about uh 45
days ago so look we're doing our due
diligence we're not out here telling
people to buy it or anything like that
on the contrary we're doing our due
diligence on it um and but we we have
accepted it we have a resolution
unanimously approved to accept it
because it's seven million dollars right
in 45 days essentially and we're also
not going to spend it right away
especially because like i said this is
sort of on this is noon and we want to
see how it plays out we want to make
sure that this is done properly that it
doesn't negatively you know affect
people obviously people buy and sell
uh of these assets uh and they make
those decisions we're not involved in
that right we're not involved in how
it's listed uh or who lists it or
anything like that or how it's priced or
anything and we don't hold any of it
we're not holding any of it um we didn't
we're not we're not part of some sort of
pre-mining or anything like that so it's
it's an interesting concept because if
um you know the market cap continues to
grow
it is possible that it could fund a
significant part of our budget and i
think that would be transformational
because it creates a broader utility for
crypto right something that has a social
benefit
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]